[Music]
[Applause]
qatar is hosting the 2022 world cup in
what is sure to be one of the most
controversial tournaments ever so here's
everything you need to know
[Music]
qatar is the smallest country to ever
host a world cup and they're also the
first islamic country to do so and while
they have huge plans for their
tournament there are also big
controversies that are almost impossible
to ignore
[Music]
the decision to give qatar the
tournament was made in 2010 with fifa
saying it would bring new audiences to
football it was also the day when russia
was handed the world cup in 2018. qatar
got 2022
but people have argued for years as to
how legitimate that decision really was
qatar
always insisted they won
qatar is a conservative state where
homosexuality is still against the law
the organizers insist that everyone is
welcome and that rainbow flags can be
flown in stadiums but some gay fans just
don't want to travel something england
manager gareth southgate has spoken
about
there are clearly
human rights issues that are of concern
you know we want a game that's inclusive
it's not a good situation that we've got
certain parts of our fan base who might
feel uncomfortable traveling to the
world cup there have also been reports
of worker rights abuses in the building
of stadiums for the tournament just how
many workers have died in the
construction of these stadiums is
disputed but all the attention has
forced qatar to improve the conditions
and rights of workers
the kafala system has been abolished
minimum wages for workers have been
introduced
regulations have been put in place to
protect the health of workers from the
heat
situations which obviously is an issue
in the summer in qatar is the situation
now perfect no are things better than
they were almost certainly yes
for the first time ever the world cup is
being played in the winter because the
summertime temperatures here are just
too hot
temperatures can reach close to 50
degrees celsius
it'll still be warm but air conditioning
inside these venues will help fans and
the players keep
cool there will be eight stadiums all
within an hour's drive of each other so
it'll feel more like an olympic games
centered on one city doha
drinking alcohol is normally limited to
hotels or private homes here in qatar
but it will be permitted in more places
than usual fan parks are expected to be
serving beer at around five pounds a
pint
many of the hotel rooms are already
booked there's apartments cruise ships
out in the bay or the most
budget-friendly option will be a
campsite here in the desert
organizers have been inspired by big
festivals where there's lots of camping
so a site is being built out here in the
desert for some of the one million
people expected to descend on qatar
throughout the tournament
favourites for the tournament include
brazil reigning champions france and
even england who reached the semifinals
in the last world cup
but european champions italy will not be
at the tournament after getting knocked
out of the qualifying playoffs by north
macedonia another team who won't be
there are russia they were removed from
the tournament after the country invaded
ukraine the world cup final on december
the 18th will inevitably feel strange
and christmas shopping and office
parties might be nudged aside in favor
of watching huge international matches
all of this means that world cup 2022
will feel like a very different
experience for the players on the pitch
for the fans here in the stadiums and
for everyone watching back home
you